one of the greatest players of all time
has a new home and what a welcome
[Applause]
after 21 years in a barcelona jersey
paris angelma have bagged lionel messi
a player with phenomenal footwork fierce
determination
and colossal earning capacity it's a
massive deal
for the lad to leave he's it's a home
now barcelona has been his home so
to leave to go to psg listen he didn't
look too unhappy today
with his paris t-shirt on and he's
obviously ready to go yesterday
was full of tears today is a new day
rumors of the move began over the
weekend his sublime skill
already missed messi had his roots in
barcelona he's never played for another
club
but being the best comes with a hefty
price tag and one his boyhood team
couldn't afford it meant an emotional
goodbye with mutual respect
his picture may have been stripped down
from the stadium grounds but his legacy
remains
so how much you willing to pay for the
best the two-year deal is worth 25
million pounds per year after tax and on
top of bonuses
he was earning well over a hundred
million pounds a year from the club
which is much much more more than double
any other
player in soccer earns its salary and
so barcelona he sort of ate the club
you know his father's constant salary
demands were unacceptable impossible for
the club to fulfill now penny said roman
is offering him
a contract that's much more befitting of
his status as the world's best player
while still remaining within the realms
of possibility
with 672 goals to his name the
expectations
couldn't be greater ashna harinag sky
news